No,
I started this whole project by looking
at Ed.
Okay.
Keep it in the data and writing the blog
that I did and hopefully will one day do
it again very soon.
Um,
and it's the best data center in the
world cause it's people,
all strangers.
I'll making judgments of one another all
probably trying to sleep with each
other,
which is also adds a certain,
uh,
pick one see to the whole thing.
Um,
so you know,
you,
you look at the data and you,
you really get a kind of special window
into people's psyche.
Got,
we kind of like,
you could see everything that was going
on in a big bunker on a Friday night.
And you know,
you see that,
that men are the kind of pursuers and
relationships that have four to one
ratio.
And it kind of correspondingly,
uh,
you know,
women because they're getting four
messages to everyone they send out,
like they respond a lot less.
Um,
and,
and response rates to track directly
with how hot the writer was is a,
but then you also see that once people
start talking,
um,
and they established a rapport,
which for Okcupid is for converse at
four,
four messages going back and forth,
that attracting,
this kind of goes out the window.
At that point,
your personality takes over after the
fourth message.
Um,
you see that,
uh,
in general women's opinions of men's
looks like,
and,
and I get an on average is about half of
what men's opinions of women's looks
are.
So they kind of get a 50% discount just
ice cold.
Uh,
on tinder it's actually a lot more,
it's something like a 10,
a 10% discount or 90% discount.
Sorry,
the other way they go at 10th.
Um,
so these environments,
I think this is,
I can't prove this.
My intuition is that the more sexual and
environment,
the larger that discount,
um,
from,
from men to women or from women to men.
Okay.
Cuba's userbase in theory on paper is as
liberal as you could ever want it to be.
You know,
you ask people if they're a Democrat,
if they're progressive,
yes,
yes.
You know,
two,
three,
one.
Um,
we're all highly coastal,
very little red state,
very blue and a piece of paper.
Okay.
Keep,
it should be a very progressive place.
And maybe it is because who knows what
the rest of the world is like,
but the data that we have,
you know,
black users get three quarters of the
messages,
the,
the positive votes,
uh,
the,
their,
their attractions ratings or three
quarters of an average white user,
um,
or,
or Latino user for that matter.
Um,
they reply to about three quarters of
the time it's pretty blanket.
Um,
Asian men also get a similar discount
but not Asian women.
And then you go and you look at at date
hookup,
which is a site we run,
um,
you look@thedataformaster.com you'll see
the exact same patterns.
Maybe not in the exact same ratios,
but the same basic up,
down.
Yes.
No pattern.
When you compare any race with another
race,
and it's kind of suggested,
it's kind of a once a universal in the
sense of permanent pattern,
but it's certainly like I state of
affairs right now in the American
psyche.
I mean,
and these three,
those three sites alone,
um,
you know,
that they registered maybe 30 million
people in the United States last year.
So it's not like some small sample.
I mean that's about half of the single
and looking people in the country to my
best guess to the,
if you look at the census numbers,
so you know,
it's,
it's pretty meaningful.
Um,
and,
and pretty depressing thing to kind of
digest,
you know,
insofar as like Grindr or any of these
other sites,
they're kind of hookup apps are hookup
apps for gay men.
Okcupid is a little bit more of the
relationship side and we have a very
strong,
um,
gay userbase men,
male and female,
and you know,
so we get to look at their patterns and
you know,
they're basically the same as straight
patterns,
you know,
which I think is
meaningful in the context of marriage
equality because it certainly the pre
marriage relationships seem about the
same when you actually go and look at
the data,
which I think is,
you know,
a strong argument for any type of
relationship being held apart legally
for sure.
Right?
Um,
I think the most significant thing that
people do on OK cupid because it's a
precursor to going out,
going home with somebody,
getting into a relationship with
somebody getting married,
any of that stuff is just messaging.
Right?
And we found some kind of crazy stuff
like,
uh,
it doesn't really matter how long your
messages,
you know,
the,
the best messages are very short,
40 to 50 characters.
But by best,
you know,
they're,
they get a reply 2120 2% of the time and
kind of all messages get a reply.
Maybe 19,
20% of the time.
So it's not like a massive increase.
Um,
it does help you to spend a little bit
more time on your message.
We put a little script to just track the
time since the composition window
opened.
And so if you put a little bit more
effort into your master's per character,
uh,
it will yield slightly better results.
But again,
you know,
it's,
it's not a huge effect.
So we were,
we were surprised at both of those
things.
I thought that longer messages we either
do super badly or do super well and that
if you spend a lot of time,
at least on your message,
it would do better than something you
just like and type it and go,
you know,
um,
as a writer,
it's a little sad to say,
but it kinda comes down to just think it
does in person.
There's so much like first impression,
which online is your picture,
frankly,
you know,
um,
that your actual words aren't as
relevant as you probably wish they were.
So to that point,
you know,
people being the kind of like intuitive
to people and math being the intuitive
genius is that they are the wisdom of
the crowds or whatever.
You know,
you have like 20% of messages from guys
to women are copy and pasted from other
messages that the guys have sent.
They just,
they found something that for whatever
reason either works or typifies them or
that they like or whatever it is,
and they just tricking,
just blast it out,
you know.
Um,
and those actually they do worse.
they do but not that much worse.
They do like 70,
75% of of a normal message,
theoretically unique message.
Um,
and so you get it,
it's very easy to arrive at,
at the,
uh,
results per unit effort is like sky
high,
just cut and pasting.
Right?
And so we at that probably will be
something that increases over time and
we don't,
we,
we thought about trying to kind of,
it's very easy for us to know whether a
message has been cut and pasted from
another message.
Obviously right now you just compare it.
Um,
but we just decided to let those things
go because,
you know,
it's,
it's just the online equivalent of,
of people having their favorite anecdote
about themselves,
or this one time they got into this
crazy bar fight or I don't know,
some dumb story how I got the scar,
that kind of thing in a bar or just like
a standard pickup line that you might
use.
So it's one of these things that the
online version of it seems very weird
and kind of unsavory to be like,
oh,
this do just sent the same message to
like 40 people.
But I've probably told the same story.
Everybody that I'm friends with,
it's probably heard a large set of the
same stories from me,
you know,
and it's something that people just do.
Okay.